Suggestions to find a dentist that are more natural and probably a
Patrick. Look for a biological dentist. So you can search Google
biological dentist near me and then look at their website and you'll see, you
know, they use mercury fillings. Do they have a mercury vacuum to remove fillings?
Do they have information on their website about the dangers of mercury fillings
and how to get them removed naturally? And then that'll give you a lot of
clues that that person is naturally minded. So I personally go to a dentist
that I wouldn't say he's a biological dentist, but we had our two youngest
children to him. We've been going to him for years. And we said we don't want
mercury fillings. And that was the first time we've been, we went to him. This was
on a couple of dozen years ago. And he said, Oh, never done this. You know, I
went, why would you put something in somebody's mouth that I have to put in a, you
know, a sharps container and haven't disposed of in a way that's, you know, not
dangerous to wear to the environment does make any sense.